لم يتبقى سوى اسبوعين وتدخل بعدها
احتجاجات ايران شهرها الثالث لا هدوء يلوح
في الافق تظاهرات عامه المدن الايرانيه
بجامعتها وطرقها ومحلاتها وحتى موظفيها
تمديدا بممارسات النظام القمعيه واحتجاجا
على مقتل الشابه مساميني النظام الايراني
يمسكوا بزمام روايه واحده رسميه هذه المره
جدد اللواء حسين سلامه قائد الحرس الثوري
اتهام الغربي بالوقوف وراء الاحتجاجات
وبدل ان يصف المتظاهرين كما جارات العاده
بمثر الشغب اتجه الى القول انهم مغرر بهم
ادعاهم الى ان يعودوا لاحضان الدوله وخلال
كلمته امام افراد قوات التعبئه اعتبر
سلامي ان الولايات المتحده عدو خارجي بل
انها من العملاء الذين يحبون خطه شريره
لاسقاط النظام حتى مرشدا النظام علي خمن
ايه اسفه على مقتل افراد قوه البسيسه فنظر
اليهم كمن ضحى بروحه من اجل احداث شغب في
ايراننا زعي من انت ان نتدخل في المرحله
الاخيره وقع لكي يحول دون تحول الشعب
الايراني لمرتزقه او لمرتهنين ما ينظر بان
دفاع خامنئي عن البسيج بهذا الشكل يمشي
بان النظام الايراني باتي ياخذ المظاهرات
على محمل الجد واعتبرها محللون سياسيون
على انها اقرار ضمني بفرضيات السوق يضاف
الى تلك التصريحات ما اشار اليه المتحدث
باسم الحكومه الايرانيه علي بها دوري جهري
الذي عبر عن ارتياحه لافراد قوات البسيج
الذين يقودون المستقبل ويجعلون الاعداء
خائفين من الجيش الصاعد
[موسيقى]
ما شاء الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
محمود مراد خاني شقيق الناشطه المدنيه
فريده مراد خاني وابنه شقيقه المرشد علي
انها اعتقلت نشر مراد خاني مقطع فيديو
لاخته من مكان اعتقالها في طهران كانت
تشهر به صوتها ضد خالها الذي يواجه الشعب
بهذه الطريقه مناشده المجتمع الدولي بعدم
التزام الصمت حول جرائم النظام واطالبه
الحرس الثوري بالعوده الى رشده والانضمام
الى صفوف المدنيه
اي انسان
عن دعم هذا النظام قاتل الاطفال هذا
النظام لا يلتزم باي من المبادئ الدينيه
ولا يعرف قانون ولا قاعده للحكم سوى القوه
والمال ليحافظ على سلطته باي طريقه ممكنه
عن طريق استدعاء جميع ممثليها من ايران
وترضي كل منتسب لهذا النظام الوحشي كطريقه
للتعبير عن التضامن مع الشعب الايراني
الساعي لليل الحريه
وبينما تحتل التظاهرات صداره المشهد في
ايران يدخل المتضامنين في ركب الانتفاضه
دون ان يسلموا من يسلم فعليا من يد النظام
القمعي حيث اعلنت صدفات فاطمه زوجه الصحفي
الرياضي الايراني مهدي امير بور عن اعتقال
زوجها بسبب تضمنه مع الاحتجاجات ونقله الى
سجن افيل بطهران بعد ان هاجم الامن منزلهم
في الساعه الثانيه بعد منتصف الليل اما
خارج البلاد كشفت المخابرات الكنديه عن
تقارير تفيد بان الايرانيين المعارضين في
كندا تلقوا تحديدات عبر الرسائل النصيه
بلغتين الفارسيه والانجليزيه تطالبهم
بالامتناع عن نفسي اي معلومه حول
الانتفاضه في وقت السابق اشتكى صحفيون
ايرانيون في بريطانيا من تهديداتنا وصفوها
بالخطيره اذ قال رئيس جهاز الامن الداخلي
البريطاني كين ما كالوم ان المخابرات
الايرانيه حاولت خطف وقت البريطانيين
مقيمين في بريطانيا على الاقل 10 مرات
صحفيه مقيم خارج ايران عليه مسؤوليه
للاستفاده من حريه التعبير المتاحه لنا
هنا وفرصه الوصول الى الانترنت والاطلاع
على محتوى كبير ياتي من داخلها وهذا شيء
يزعج النظام الايراني الى حد كبير
الاجهزه
او عمليه اغتيال او شيء من هذا القبيل
وبحسب البيانات وكاله انباء نشطاء حقوق
الانسان هرانا قتل حتى يوم امس نحو 450
محتجا منهم 63 طفلا فضلا عن اعتقال اكثر
من 18 الفا من المتظاهرين وكذلك 156 مدينه
ايرانيه مسرحا لمناهض النظام بالرغم من
التعتيم على الاسماء الا ان الوكاله تعرفت
على هويه قرابه ثلاثه الاف من المعتقلين
كما واصدر النظام القضائي في ايران احكاما
باعدام سته محتاجين على الاقل منذ بدايه
الاحتجاجات ومع توجيه اتهامات للالاف بسبب
مشاركتهم في هذه الاضطرابات حسب ما ذكر
بيان المنظمه